the u.s and saudi arabia have deep ties
that go back
decades ties that connect washington and
riyadh
and both countries economies the
countries are so intertwined
economically
that washington is often reluctant to
distance itself from riyadh politically
the current tension over the death of
washington post journalist
jamal khashoggi is no exception here's a
look at some of the glue
that's binding the two powers together
first
saudi arabia and the u.s are connected
by oil
the u.s has doubled production of crude
over the past decade and is now
considered the world's largest producer
but it still looks to saudi arabia for
nearly 10 percent of its petroleum
imports
and there's more saudi arabia holds the
power to quickly influence global oil
prices
some call it the central bank of oil
that's because in saudi arabia the state
controls oil production
which allows for a more streamlined
operation than in countries like the us
where hundreds of private companies work
independently
across numerous states the kingdom has
the power to turn the flow
up and down quickly impacting gas prices
inflation and global growth saudi
financiers have also forged
close relationships with american
companies especially in tech and finance
that's because crown prince mohammed bin
salman has set the ambitious goal of
making saudi arabia
a major investment hub in an effort to
diversify the country's economy beyond
oil
using the country's public investment
fund the saudis have
directly invested 3.5 billion dollars in
uber
which gave pif's chief a seat on the
company's board
taking a roughly five percent stake in
tesla which fueled speculation that it
could take over the company someday
and committed 45 billion dollars to a
tech fund managed by softbank
a japanese firm that's investing heavily
in u.s startups like wework
since 2016 the kingdom has become the
biggest single source of funding for u.s
startups
thais are also growing stronger with
wall street pif committed
up to 20 billion dollars for an
infrastructure fund managed by
blackstone
and blackrock the world's largest asset
manager
has met with the crown prince about
possible investment partnerships
and is planning to open an office in
saudi arabia however there's one caveat
some of saudi arabia's ambitious
business plans have been put on hold
due to the stalled ipo of saudi aramco
the country's massive state-owned oil
company
then there are the arms and defense
deals for decades the u.s has provided
military support for saudi arabia
and the kingdom has purchased tens of
billions of dollars of weapons and
defense systems from the united states
the u.s defense industry is so
entrenched in saudi arabia that some
american companies are establishing
joint ventures
to make and repair equipment in saudi
arabia
in 2017 the u.s and saudi arabia
announced an
arms deal they said could eventually be
worth 110
billion dollars that's peanuts for you
should have increased it
these contracts some of which have yet
to be approved would benefit a handful
of u.s companies
lockheed martin said in a statement that
it amassed 28 billion dollars in
potential new business from saudi arabia
including the planned sale of combat
ships and helicopters that would be
assembled at a new plant
in saudi arabia creating 450 jobs there
it also struck a deal to sell its thaad
missile defense system to the kingdom
raytheon said it was setting up a new
saudi-based defense arm
encompassing munitions and cyber
security and boeing was approved to sell
saudi arabia
seven billion dollars in chinook and
apache helicopters
and it announced a joint venture in
march that would create 6 000
saudi jobs boeing has said its share of
the planned deals could be worth as much
as
50 billion dollars trump has made it
clear he does not want to jeopardize
deals like these
even in light of political controversies
if we don't sell it to them they'll say
well thank you very much we'll buy it
from russia
or thank you very much we'll buy it from
china so what good does that do us
there are other things we can do some
u.s business leaders have distanced
themselves from the kingdom after
khashoggi's disappearance
by pulling out of the saudi conference
dubbed davos in the desert but the
country's economic ties
run deep and the alliance has proven to
be a resilient one